Okay, my name is Eugene.
My name is Eugene.
I'm a hustler and I'm still schooling.
Okay, I have two question to you and uh
please make me satisfied. Please
uh I will ask the first question. Uh
I've been having the conversation
between uh me myself and uh my friend
and we are talking about this Islamic uh
prophet. We found
the prophet the first prophet is an Adam
and according to me the first prophet I
think is not Adam. So kindly please I
just want you to tell me uh how the
first prophet is Adam and I want to know
more about this Muhammad because to me
as a Christian I've never seen in a
Bible um
Muhammad I want you to ask just try to
convince me and uh help me understand
the first prophet and the work of
prophet I will ask the another question
after I've being satisfied.
>> My brother's name is Eugene.
He's asking a question. Who was the
first prophet? According to him, he's
saying there is a prophet before Adam.
>> No,
>> after Adam.
>> After Adam, who is the second prophet?
>> His question is he saying Adam is not a
prophet.
>> So, who was the first prophet?
Correct.
>> The brother spoke about six sentences.
You translate in one sentence.
>> Don't cut short.
>> Plus, he wanted to know who is Muhammad
from the Bible.
>> Okay. The brother has asked two
question. Number one, who was Adam? He
does not believe Adam was a prophet.
And he wants to know who is Muhammad.
Brother, as per the Bible, the first
messenger, first prophet as per the
Bible is Adam peace be upon him. Even in
the Quran, the first prophet first in
the Quran is Adam peace be upon him.
Prophet means Allah chooses a man
amongst men to deliver the message to
humanity.
So, prophet Adam was the first prophet.
He was sent down on this earth and all
those who came after him, he preached
the message. God will not leave human
beings without a messenger. He has
promised that in the Quran. So Adam was
the first messenger, first prophet as
per the Quran, as per the Bible. Is it
clear? Who was Prophet Muhammad? I said
earlier, Prophet Muhammad is the last
and final messenger which was not only
sent for the Muslims or the Arabs. He
was sent for the whole of humanity. All
the previous messengers and prophet they
were sent for a particular group of
group of people only for the their
people not for the whole world not for
the whole universe. Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him was not sent only for
the Muslims or the Arabs. He was sent
for the whole of humanity. Hope that
answers the question.
>> Okay. My second question is coming like
uh I want you to refer you back uh for
what you say yesterday.
Uh you told us that if I'm a if I have a
friend who is an Islam Islamic and I'm a
Christian so that bond of being
friendship will not be so much close so
that I I can help her or him. Okay. Is
that uh away or just you tell me
convince me?
>> Brother Eugene is asking a question
regarding your yesterday's talk
>> about about yesterday's talk.
Yesterday's talk.
>> Yes.
>> About him as a Christian having a Muslim
friend. Their friendship bond won't be
that strong.
>> Their friendship will not be
>> strong.
>> Will be strong.
>> Will not be strong because his friend is
a Muslim and he's a Christian.
So what the question
can
>> so his question is him being as a
Christian can he help his Muslim friend
or not?
>> The brothers asked the question that he
has a Muslim friend. He a Christian the
friendship is not very strong to make
the friendship strong.
If you see the difference between you
Christian and your friend is that you
believe in all the prophets from Adam to
Noah, Abraham, Moses, Jesus. Correct? We
Muslims believe in all the prophets
mentioned right from Adam, Abraham,
Moses, Jesus. What we tell you? Why
don't you believe in one more prophet?
Prophet Muhammad which is prophesized by
Jesus. In the earlier answer I gave you
that prophet Muhammad is prophesized in
your Bible. So why don't you follow the
Bible and believe in Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him?
Question.
>> Do you believe in Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him?
>> Do you believe that Prophet Muhammad was
the messenger of God? Okay. It will not
be I will not try to say yes because
I'll take time.
>> No, don't say yes if you don't believe
in it.
>> I don't
>> say yes only if you believe.
>> Oh, I don't believe.
>> Do you believe Jes Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God?
>> I don't believe.
>> That means you don't believe in Jesus
peace be upon him. Because Jesus said
peace be upon him. In Gospel of John
chapter number 16 verse number 7, it is
expedient for you that I go away. For if
I go not away, the comforter shall not
come. For if I go, shall I send him.
Gospel of John, chapter number 16, verse
number 12 to 14. Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him, says, I have many things to
say unto you, but he cannot bear them
now. For he, when the spirit of truth,
shall come, he shall guide you onto all
throats. He shall not speak of himself.
All that shall he speak, he shall
glorify me. So there are many verses in
the Bible, in the Old Testament. I gave
the references in the New Testament
where Jesus Christ peace be upon him
says prophet Muhammad is a messenger. So
don't you believe in the preaching and
the teachings of Jesus peace be upon
him.
>> I believe in your preaching.
>> If you believe in the teachings of
Jesus, you have to believe in the last
and final message. How? Just because
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
it's mentioned in the Quran. Jesus is a
prophet. I believe in him. Why? Because
I love Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him. Islam is the only non-Christian
faith which makes it an article of faith
to believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him. No Muslim is a Muslim if he does
not believe in Jesus Christ peace be
upon him. We believe that he was one of
the mightiest messengers of God. We
believe that he was born miraculously
without any male intervention. We
believe that he healed those born blind
and lepers with God's permission. We are
going together. So just because prophet
Muhammad said that I believe. So
similarly when Jesus speaks ABOUT
PROPHET JESUS WHY DON'T YOU BELIEVE in
him?
>> I do.
>> Oh so you believe in prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him.
>> Okay according to the way you convince
me I will just believe.
>> No no no prophet m prophet Jesus
prophesized the coming of prophet
Muhammad. I have many things to say unto
you but he CANNOT BEAR THEM NOW. I will
give you a comforter TALKING ABOUT
PROPHET MUHAMMAD. I GAVE A FULL TALK on
Prophet Muhammad in the Bible in
Nairobi. I just gave the references just
a few minutes before. Yes or no? All
from the Bible, Old Testament, New
Testament. Then I'm asking you, do you
believe that Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger?
>> I do believe.
>> Mashallah, you believe? Do you believe
there's one God?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you believe Jesus is a messenger of
God?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God?
>> Yeah.
>> Then you're a Muslim, mashallah. I know.
>> Huh?
>> No.
>> I love fellowshipping.
>> I love I I love fellowshipping.
>> Sorry.
>> I love fellowshipping. Okay.
>> You love
>> fellowshipping. Asking question about
God.
>> You love
>> fellowshipping. Fellowshipping.
>> Can you repeat?
>> He loves fellowship.
>> Fellowshipping.
>> Yeah.
>> What is fellowship?
>> Like coming together having sharing the
word of God.
>> No. No. We love each other. And I'm
asking you if you believe in two things
for any human being to be a Muslim
minimum two things are required. Believe
that there is one God which you believe
prophet Jesus is a messenger which you
believe and believe prophet Muhammad to
be a messenger of God which you believe.
So these are the minimum two things
minimum two beliefs for any human being
to become a Muslim. So once you believe
in these two things you become a Muslim.
Muslim means one who submits his will to
God. Whatever God says, you follow.
So do you believe there's one God?
>> Yeah.
>> You believe Prophet Muhammad is the
messenger of God.
>> Yeah.
>> That means you're a Muslim.
So if you believe Muhammad is a
messenger, should you not follow the
messenger of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam?
>> I am to follow.
>> Very good. That means you're a Muslim.
>> No.
So what are you then?
>> A Christian.
>> What is the meaning of the word
Christian?
>> Christian means a person who follows the
teachings of Jesus Christ. Even I follow
the teachings of Jesus Christ. But if
you say you worship Jesus Christ as God,
then you are wrong. But if you say Jesus
is a messenger, I want to follow the
teachings of Jesus peace be upon him,
correct teachings, and then I want to
follow the teachings of Prophet
Muhammad. No problem.
But if you say I want to worship Jesus,
then there's a problem.
>> So do you worship Jesus or do you
believe Jesus is a messenger?
>> I believe Jesus is a messenger.
>> Mashallah. Very good. That means you're
a Muslim.
>> No.
If you believe that Jesus is a messenger
and you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger, Muslim means a person who
submits his will to God. Do you want to
follow the will of God?
>> Yeah.
>> That means you're a Muslim.
If Christian means
see they're happy.
But I don't I don't want to force you.
If you believe prophet Muhammad is a
messenger, you believe there is one God
and yet if you don't say you're a Muslim
then you have to understand more about
it.
>> Yeah.
>> Correct.
>> So you understand more.
>> Yeah.
>> You read the Quran.
>> No.
>> I'm asking you to read the Quran. Maybe
someone will give you the translation.
>> I request the volunteer to give this
brother the translation of the Quran and
we pray to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala to
guide him.
Thank you brother.
>> Okay.